mais aucune dans l'ambiance avec cet
extrait c'est au final du match qu'a
disputé la québécoise les là annie
fernandez ya quelques heures à peine
elle est âgée de 16 ans imaginez
maintenant championne juniors à roland
garros je l'a joint à paris en direct
bonjour là bonjour comment allez vous
vois très bien toutes nos félicitations
parlez nous de votre sentiment de cette
belle victoire
je suis très contente bien il ya pas de
mot à dire que je me sens maintenant ou
après le marché que j'ai travaillé très
fort par les années avec mon père qui
mon côté avec ma petite fleur et que je
suis pourtant que j'ai pu gagner
aujourd'hui mais c'est tout une histoire
de famille pour vous on le voyait
d'ailleurs dans un des reportages de
présenter à un podium
la semaine dernière les lans votre
famille est avec vous tennis canada est
également la semaine dernière vous avez
remporté le tournoi de charleroi en
belgique vous deviez les gens que
c'était un tournoi extrêmement important
pour vous mais là roland-garros vraiment
oui bien sûr j'étais très content que
j'ai pu gagner
charleroi les gradins belgique qui ça
m'a donné beaucoup de confiance pour
venir ici en france à paris pour eux
jouer leur rôle en gare aux juniors
j'étais très jeune et les premières
rondes mais je suis content que d'être
ici en france avec mon père et la volée
de tennis canada qui était avec moi qui
m'ont aidée par les deux semaines et et
je suis content d'avoir séduit comme
quand vous avez commencé le tournoi ce
que vous y croyez vraiment que c'était
possible de remporter la finale
willis il que tous les tourments que je
rentre assez pour gagner et que si je me
suis pour un tournage parce que je crois
que je suis prêt pour gagner ce tournoi
et quand je suis
à paris j'étais très importante et je
voulais juste armes ont mieux joué mon
jeu que je m'entraîne avec mon coach
jean flori t2 et de l'agonie avec la
détermination des des champions à ceux
ci ce qu'on entend les leurs on parle
beaucoup rangs des joueurs canadiens qui
s'impose sur la scène internationale est
ce que est ce que ça vous inspire ça
vous motive
est ce que ça vous a encouragé au cours
des derniers mois vous dire moi aussi je
suis capable de m'imposer comme ça oui
bien sûr quelqu'un j'ai vu 2 n'échappe
au volant cavani contre rafael nadal à
la coupole c'était quelque chose
spéciale et j'ai cru que vont les
joueurs canadiens en tant que mots si je
pourrais être là vécu que je pouvais
être ici à paris en train de jouer
roland-garros la finale émerveillé alors
maintenant quel est votre long match
pour les prochaines semaines ou moins
honnêtement je ne sais pas mais
peut-être faire un tour dans la semaine
prochaine en soixante mille à barcelone
où je prends quelques jours de repos est
allé en sus pour supporter ma petite
soeur qui juin était junior à 3 donc
votre sert aussi donc vous encourager
l'une et l'autre est ce qu'on va voir au
tournoi de wimbledon
number nine
il veut pas faire un beau jeune parce
que j'ai joué le tournoi de wta les
25000 à winnipeg et à carnot puis après
80 mg b et là la coupe rogers a et bien
ça va nous faire grand plaisir d'aller
vous encourager sur place dont on vous
voir dans différents tournois à travers
le canada dès les prochaines semaines
lula à luis fernandez
merci de nous avoir parlé en direct ce
matin donc quelques heures après avoir
remporté le championnat donc de
roland-garros championnat
niort merci beaucoup merci beaucoup au
revoir